ladies ready
this way I'm scared don't be scared
Martin just remember the company values
integrity kindness prompt delivery we're
on our way to victory JA I have been in
logistics for 15 years and that was a
fantastic battle fought with bravery
we got to the other side of the room and
we hit all our targets why are we here
why do we do this why did she have to
die
why demands have to die for this just so
you could get your bonus
what was the purpose of all of this
you
you
okay so the whole thing is pretty simple
just yeah
just go into the software back-end
and then you type xwk wk1 and then you
move the cursor to the left and you find
a little widget called about then you go
in and type in the input data there
after you download the incoming
overnight figures put them through the
algorithm then you'll need to get
something to feed into Excel ready for
the presentation tomorrow get it
can you just um can you just go over
that glass just can you just do that
last bit which bit just the typing bit
um honestly you know I'm really busy
I've got a conference call with Germany
share with us overseas yeah
biggie you're a bright spot you're all
right when you get to know ya why don't
you download the help manual it's all in
there you'll be fine
okay I love it
when an employee just gets it like that
that's cracking you for doing anything
nice for the weekend
and and figures July where are they
what month is it yeah I need July
figures by June don't I guys this this
is what I've been saying about have a
like all this time you leading me into
having a breakdown Hey right
July figures in June
[Music]
that there is my office take some people
call it the pressure box that's more
like it
it is dog-eat-dog out there
scrapper Sharkey bloody shark
it's not good enough it's not good
enough we please pull together the fire
drill Tuesday it's not a test
[Music]
you
guys okay guys listen up Linda Linda
Linda okay
Thursday creative day so let's all get
our creative juices flowing dan from
finances actually done a little bit of a
talk for us he'd like to called
Sebastian today but if we could all head
into the room please guys everyone come
I've got a few phone calls to make this
morning yeah ignore the phone calls it's
fine call Martin you try your best today
I said grab a seat guys have a seat
so to channel my creativity so we're
more empowered human beings we're going
to channel our inner animal so you've
got an animal in front of you great
hives already put on the the kinky
crocodile
Martin do you want to find your Tiger
the grass the savanna grass is brushing
your side flanks you see an antelope how
does that make you feel
don't vocalize it just kind of act it
that's good that's brilliant yeah well
done boss
right okay that's it guys seriously
let's get back in there you know those
phones are gonna answer themselves
actually there is quite a few calls on
your desk over a little bunches but
thank you guys thank you guys
same time next week
remember Friday fire drill okay snot
test it's a real one
you